we are told that a racecar driver has 28
cars each car has four tires he has to
replace all the tires on the cars he has
22 tires right now estimate the total
number of tires he needs to buy so pause
this video and see if you can do that
and the key word here is estimates you
don't have to figure out exactly you
seem to figure it out roughly the total
number of tires he needs to buy all
right now let's work through this
together and as I mentioned the key word
here is estimate and estimating is
something we'll do throughout our lives
I probably do it
once a day at least and when you're
estimating you want to make all the
numbers roughly right but also think
about hey what what I need a how do I
need to think about them in order to
make the computation a little bit easier
or a little bit friendlier so if I
wanted to figure out exactly how many
tires he needed to buy I would say hey
he has 28 cars he has 28 cars each car
has four tires
so each car has four tires so if you
wanted to know the total number of tires
you would multiply 28 times four and
then it says he has to replace all the
tires on the car and if he didn't have
any this is the number that he would
have to replace but it says he has 22
tires right now so if we were trying to
figure out exactly you would say 28
times four that's how many he needs to
replace but he already has 22 so you
subtract that out and then this whole
number would be the number he needs to
buy now this calculation isn't so easy
to do especially if you're doing it on a
napkin or in your head but that's why
we're going to estimate so if we're
estimating we say hey what's up what's a
friendlier number than 28 well 28 pretty
close to 30 so I could say so if I say
hey 28 is pretty close to 30 so that's
our way of making the 28 a little bit
friendlier 4 is already pretty easy to
deal with and then the 22 well that
could be a lot easier to deal with if
instead of it being a 22 if that were
let's say that's approximately equal to
20 so 22 is approximately roughly equal
that's what these squiggly equal signs
mean to 20 and so
simplifies the calculation a lot we
could say that this thing up here is
roughly equal to he roughly has 30 cars
and each of those cars need four tires
and then he's going to figure out the
total number of tires he needs to
replace but then he subtracts out the
number that he already has so instead of
subtracting out 22 we're gonna subtract
out roughly how many he already has
roughly 20 and this computation right
here is a lot easier to do in our head
three times four is 12 so 30 times four
is 120 so this part right over here is
120 and then you subtract 20 from that
well 120 minus 20 well that is going to
be 100 so he roughly needs if I were to
estimate the total number of tires he
needs to buy it would be about 100 tires